bonjour céline ricker merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france on a entendu notre reporter
qui va suivre cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui c'est une grève de quelle
manière vous organisez vous aujourd'hui
pour faire entendre vos revendications
bonjour donc on va se rassembler pour
essayer de se faire entendre
je pense que la plupart des maternités
toutes les sages femmes voilées
grévistes les sages femmes libérales
ferment leur cabinet donc ça veut dire
qu'on peut pas te faire deux sorties
précoces
voilà et non gérera que les urgences on
va essayer dans les maternités aussi de
faire appel au médecin dès que ça
dépasse nos compétences et de rester
dans notre rôle propre pour voilà de
montrer que on est essentiel dans pour
les naissances alors justement vous êtes
l'essentiel et vous dites que vos
compétences ne sont pas reconnus
quels sont vos compétences et que que
réclamez-vous finalement des deux
meilleurs salaires et une reconnaissance
de ses compétences de quelle manière
exactement le salaire c'est quand même
là la grosse revendications puisque
c'est ce qui touche tout le monde
précisément comment les unes sa soeur
aujourd'hui commence à 1700 euros après
cinq années d'études en passant par la
première année de médecine c'est quand
même une fable reconnaissance la
reconnaissance comme l'a très bien dit
votre reporter tout à l'heure on en a
c'est pas un centime en laisse
systématiquement oublier encore dans son
centre 8
emmanuel macron le 1er mai remercier
tous les professionnels vaccinant et
avait au départ il ya la correction a
été faite après 2 donc message des sages
femmes mais les vétérinaires les
dentistes sont cités mais les
sages-femmes points alors qu'on qu'on
peut vacciner toute la population
prescrire et vaccinés de façon générale
vous le faites là je manque de
reconnaissance il est tous les jours
oui vous auriez peut être mise à
contribution pour la vaccination c'est
vous dites on participe à la vaccination
on est autorisé à prescrire on est
autorisé à vacciner toutes les personnes
qui sont autorisés à être vaccinés on
peut les vacciner sauf que ce soit dans
son discours ou dans son tweet du 1er
mai est bien ici il ne nous suit pas il
cite les vétérinaires mais ne suit pas
les sages femmes qui pourtant sont là un
premier recours on a les cabinets
libéraux qui sont présents il ya des
sages femmes qui sont sur les gros
centres de vaccination voilà on est là
on peut le faire il faut il faut pas
nous oublier
et en plus on le sait peut-être moi mais
les sages femmes parfois son fond seul
aux commandes si je fais dire pour faire
accoucher les femmes
exactement je 80 % des naissances sont
gérés comme totalement par les sages
femmes sans intervention des médecins
dans les petites maternités les
cliniques les hôpitaux au nail à 100% du
temps avec les femmes qui vont accoucher
les médecins sont là que qu'en cas de
pathologies si on a besoin de ces c'est
pas c'est pas eux qui assurent la
surveillance ni les gestes de première
urgence
on s'occupe aussi de la réanimation du
nouveau né et puis nos compétences nous
avons posé la question elles sont aussi
beaucoup plus large que ça c'est à dire
qu'on peut maintenant assurée tout le
suivi gynécologique des femmes les
premières consultations des de
contraception le la pause des stériles
aide
des implants on peut participer aux ivg
médical on pratiquer les ivg médicale en
fin de notre faim de compétence est
vraiment très large et pour la santé des
femmes je pense que le mieux nous
reconnaître ce c ces avantages et là la
prise en charge de toutes ces femmes
on manque de gynécologues aujourd'hui
des sages femmes sont présentes pour
prendre le relais tant que tout va bien
que ce n'est que de la physiologie
puisqu'on doit rester dans notre rôle de
dakar à venir que pour la physiologie et
de dépister ce qui est pathologique pour
adresser un suite aux médecins il faut
qu'on le soit reconnu et qu'on ait notre
place pour améliorer la prise en charge
des femmes auraient d'autant que vous
vous exercez aussi dans des conditions
difficiles avec le virus mais des
conditions aussi difficiles en temps
normal qu'elles sont ces conditions vous
dénoncez également vous dites que les
maternités sont devenus des usines les
usines les effectifs sont complètement
insuffisant ils sont sont régis par des
décrets qui date de 1998
depuis il n'y a quand même eu de
nombreuses fermetures de maternités donc
des boucles du gros centre on constate
aussi une augmentation de la pathologie
ça c'est l'autre c'est un autre problème
mais il ya quand même de grosses prises
en charges qui sont lourdes
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le slogan une
femme une sage-femme est essentiel pour
avancer dans les effectifs en maternité
pour qu'on puisse réellement être auprès
des femmes les accompagner et assurer la
surveillance des deux de ses patientes
et de leur nouveau né ou tu de l'enfant
à naître
surtout moi je me suis vu sortir d'une
salle d'accouchement juste après un
accouchement avoir juste le temps de me
laver les mains pour attraper un autre
bébé dans une deuxième salle
d'accouchement
on ne peut pas dire que j'ai assuré le
suivi de cette patiente c'est pas
possible
quand vous dites que la rentabilité
prime sur l'humain qu'est ce que vous
voulez
dire mais on constate qu'il faut faire
très rapidement les sorties de maternité
pour laisser la place on ferme des lits
donc on réduit les effectifs et et on
n'a pas le temps d'en d'entourer les
patientes comme il le faut je le la
maternité s'est enfin devenir mère c'est
quand même quelque chose de pur la vie
d'une femme
c'est un gros changement c'est un
nouveau né ne s'est pas finalement à
voir ce qui va comment on va gérer c'est
toujours différent et sat accompagnement
on n'arrive pas à le faire on a
l'impression parfois de mettre les
femmes dehors sans les avoir réellement
accompagner heureusement il ya des sages
femmes libérales qui peuvent un petit
peu s'en occuper mais c'est pareil elles
sont pas forcément suffisamment
présentes sur le territoire pour pour
rassurer tout où cet accompagnement il y
aurait besoin de beaucoup plus de
d'accompagnement fait pour que les
maires soient à l'aise avec leur nouveau
né et que les halètements soit bien
qu'on l'ait d allaitement beaucoup plus
long beaucoup plus d'allaitement c'est
c'est aussi important pour les
nouveau-nés enfin merci beaucoup c'est
une rigueur on va suivre évidemment ces
manifestations aujourd'hui sur notre
antenne merci d'avoir répondu en direct
ce matin à nos questions sur la mairie
voilà ça me laisse juste le temps
d'aller prendre le train pour retrouver
la manifestation est même bon courage à
vous merci beaucoup